um
it may be hard to believe that products
based on racial stereotypes survived
well into the 21st century
there was always these friends i had
breakfast with they always would take
out their angelima jug i haven't really
heard of any other syrup so i usually
just gravitate towards that one
it just seems like a
super exploitation of a stereotype
it took widespread protests in 2020 to
send some companies a wake-up call
but even as some of this controversial
branding slowly disappears off store
shelves
there could be an even more insidious
and harder to fix form of racial bias
coded into the technologies that have
become ubiquitous in everyday life
start your day with natural freshness
from darley one of the most popular
toothpaste brands in east asia southeast
asia is called darley toothpaste
darley is owned by colgate palmolive and
a local partner and has a long history
goes back to i think 1930s and it
originally started out as [ __ ]
toothpaste
the packaging was pretty explicit it had
a picture of minstrel singer and
blackface on the package with the big
smile with white teeth this came about
at a time when movies like the jazz
singer with al jolson were very popular
[Music]
[ __ ] toothpaste gives you a cool fresh
tingling taste
you see
how this is working in terms of
marketing you know there's nothing wrong
with
wanting white teeth
but when you contrast that with this jet
black
person
the message is very clear
if you don't want to have dark teeth you
don't want anything dark
use [ __ ] it will solve that
[Music]
they changed the name in english to
darlee so one letter gets rid of the
problem they also got rid of the
packaging so it was no longer just a
picture of a man in blackface on the box
it was somebody who was in a top hat and
it was a black and white contrast still
getting the point across like look black
white but it wasn't black face that said
though they didn't change the name in
chinese
the issue of having these kind of brands
with these racist legacies it's it's a
bit more complicated here in asia than
it is in other parts of the world in
part just because
of the the different racial dynamics in
in asia
you don't have a lot of black people and
so people just
don't think about these issues the same
way
so
there's less pressure domestically to do
anything about them
meanwhile across the world the united
states has its own version of the dali
story in a product familiar to many
people on their breakfast table
there were two black families in the
town i grew up in
and aunt jemima was literally the only
black person i knew most of my life
we used to use it a lot when we were
like kids and making like pancakes in
the morning and using the syrup too
i had like good memories from like my
childhood using it all the time well i
don't necessarily think andre mima was
racist i felt like it was a brand that
named it by that and it's nothing more
than that really
at the time of unchamas inception 1889
this was something where it was marketed
to white folks
you have this very recent memory back
then of just slavery what it meant to
people
and what subservience meant in terms of
not only a proposition but
a role in the american way
the
gentleman who
came up with the idea for the angelima
motif and brand uh chris rutt he
attended a minstrel show in missouri in
the 1880s where he saw a white man in
blackface
performing
a minstrel role as a mammy
to target and make fun of
african-americans but also
african-american women
and it's out of that
performance that rut got together with
his collaborator a guy by the name of
underwood
to come up with this marketing strategy
for the pearl milling company's brand of
self-raising flour
in the 1920s quaker oats bought pearl
milling company increasing the market
share and cultural presence of the brand
around the same time mob violence and
new forms of repression against african
americans were becoming more widespread
in the small missouri town where the
milling company behind aunt jemimas was
based a 19 year old black man was
lynched in 1933 after he was accused of
making a pass at a white woman
that's the immediate context because if
you think about it
in comparison to
um the sort of brutal lynching of a
young african-american
man
aunt jemima's something very different
it's a contrast to that sort of threat
of black masculinity
aunt jemima is
the embodiment of the sort of safe loyal
trusting house servant of slavery times
so that imagery of aunt jemima was both
reassuring and nostalgic to white
americans and particularly white
southerners
nostalgia is an important emotion people
people buy products on
emotion for generations frosty mornings
have seemed warmer with stacks of
buckwheats
quaker tweaked the brand image over time
replacing the kerchief on the aunt
jemima character's head with a plaid
hairband in 1968
and again in 1989 by adding pearl
earrings a lace collar and then
fashionable perm hairstyle it's got more
maple in it
in the early 90s a commercial campaign
starring performer gladys knight tried
to further normalize aunt jemima by
showing how much african americans
themselves loved the product
but even after the brand was acquired by
pepsico in 2001 some still felt that the
minor branding shifts over the years
were mostly a convenient corporate
distraction from a lingering racial bias
anchormama was a very strong brand
strong enough wear was never
discontinued and when we look at these
products the ethos of them and just
being easy ready-made products that was
the whole design to bring in these
caricatures to convey this
ease as if you have this
person mammy in your kitchen cooking the
pancakes for you it's that easy that
it's as if someone else did it for you
so racism is commerce and in terms of
this marketing unfortunately it was
hinged on a lot of this and jemima
buttermilk pancakes perfect pancakes and
10 shakes
this is a classic example of a
corporation commercializing and
capitalizing
uh on racial stereotypes
and making in the process billions and
billions of dollars in profit
aunt jemima is history quaker oats
announcing today that it is retiring
both the logo and the name of the 130
year old brand
quaker the latest company to take action
as demonstrations protesting racial
inequality continue across the country
pepsico has recognized that we are in
one of those moments
and that's
to not lose market share and to seem as
though it's continuing to be relevant
they need to make this this attempt and
so they've done that with the pearl
milling company branding
now the pearl milling company branding
sort of hearkened backs to the very
beginning of this in saint joseph
missouri that era in relation to racial
violence i don't know that it goes far
enough
to separate it from that racist
and oppressive past
that so many african-american people
were exposed to
[Music]
while aunt jemima was probably the most
notorious mainstream brand to face a
reckoning after the 2020 protests a few
others such as lander lakes and uncle
ben's have also come under scrutiny in
the wake of the renewed conversations
around systematic racism
as corporations continue to navigate how
to address racial stereotypes in
advertising while still protecting
profits there's a whole other arena now
where the problem of embedded racism may
be even harder to detect and harder to
stamp out
i think my blackness is interfering with
the computer's ability to to follow me
as you can see i do this
no following
not really not really following me i
back up
i get really really close to try to let
the camera recognize me not happening
now
my white coworker wanda is about to
slide in the frame you will immediately
see
what i'm talking about wand if you would
please
sure
it stems from the roots and ai is just
the next
branch everything is the
exact same when it comes to the
application the technology behind it
because when you look at who's in the
room
it's not black people who are
testing these ai algorithms the system i
was using worked well on my lighter
skinned friend's face but when it came
to detecting my face
it didn't do so well until i put on a
white mask
there's a really groundbreaking piece of
research that i think many people sort
of associate with this you know concern
and movement around ai fairness and bias
and that's some 2018 research done by um
joy bulamini and timnit gebrew they were
trying to figure out whether popular
facial recognition programs could
correctly pick out the the gender of
different photographs and what they
found was that the facial recognition
software that they looked at which was
from microsoft ibm and face plus plus
misidentified darker skinned women far
more frequently and a few months later
along with deborah raji published a
subsequent paper that looked at amazon's
cloud facial recognition program which
is called recognition
[Music]
they were already pitching it for use by
police and by immigration services and
we pretty much said well these products
are already out there in the market do
they actually work for faces that look
like ours darker female faces
what we found was that these models were
performing at less than 70 accuracy for
darker female faces while performing at
pretty much 100 accuracy for lighter
male faces revealing a discrepancy in
the performance of these systems for
different demographic groups and in
particular sort of endangering the lives
of those that would be impacted by the
deployment of these systems
eventually microsoft fixed its facial
recognition software and big tech
companies including amazon and ibm said
they would stop selling facial
recognition products to the police
some local governments have also passed
laws regulating facial recognition
software or banning its use in policing
but there's no federal law regulating
its use
at the same time there are other
companies that sells their facial
recognition software to police
departments and there have been at least
three cases of black men who are suing
because they say that they were wrongly
flagged by this facial recognition
software police came after them because
you know the software told them that
they were they were you know a suspect
they were looking for this is what
happened in the case of robert williams
who was you know one of the first
recorded cases of a false facial
recognition match escalating to a false
arrest
i picked that paper up and hold it next
to my face
and i said
this is not me
i'm like i hope y'all don't think all
black people look alike
and then he says the computer says it's
you
facial recognition is not the only
example of algorithmic bias
machine learning a subset of ai powers
many technologies huge data sets are
used to train machine learning models to
make predictions
so we want a computer for example to
learn the difference between
a doc and a cat we can show the computer
a lot of examples of what a dog looks
like show the computer a lot of examples
of what a cat looks like and as a result
of that the computer kind of figures out
that well pointy ears means a cat you
know whiskers might mean a cat floppy
ears means a dog
and uses these features in order to
differentiate between any new image that
i might see of what could potentially be
a dog or cat if all of your cats are
white and all of your dogs are great and
black what happens if you put in a photo
of a black cat
all of the cats that this algorithm has
learned are cats are white everything
that it's seen as black is a dog and so
the algorithm may decide oh this is
black it must be a dog in reality it's a
black cat
sometimes a data set that lacks
diversity is the problem other times the
design of the model is the issue
it can be a completely unaccountable
process these data sets are so large the
ai system
is analyzing
data that they
haven't they can't even know the full
scope of it's sort of on the order of
millions and millions of examples the
algorithm is sort of
identifying patterns in order to create
a relationship between inputs and
outputs
but those patterns are not necessarily
things that humans can understand or see
very well
these algorithms should be able to learn
over time they should be able to
incorporate new data
from the people using it even if you
create an algorithm you check it for
bias and it's fine the new data the way
people use the algorithm could warp the
algorithm over time and make it biased
you know as an example of what could go
wrong the propublica article looked at
software that's used to predict future
criminals who is more likely or less
likely to commit a crime and a
pro-public investigation found that that
algorithm which was pretty widely used
was biased against black people and the
issue here is that that algorithm gets
used for all sorts of things it gets
used for deciding who gets uh you know
what sort of bail who gets what sort of
sentence who gets parole and the
algorithm was uh you know considering
black um defendants as a greater risk
than white defendants and and propublica
tracked some of these cases and actually
turned out that the the white defendant
um did reoffend and the black defendant
didn't
the unwillingness on the part of some
tech companies to fully disclose their
algorithms makes it hard to hold them
accountable
in april the u.s federal trade
commission warned that it could crack
down on companies that use bios ai
software but overall regulation has been
slow
so we're only going to see
these ai systems being more and more
prevalent sort of invisibly
ubiquitous
in society if we don't do a good job of
really thinking about how we're going to
hold them accountable now it's going to
be even much more difficult later on to
try to reel things back
just as with the ongoing fight to create
more equitable political and
socio-economic systems overcoming racism
in product design may require more than
simply renaming rebranding or recoding
these changes although helpful only
scratched the surface of the deeper
problem it just says a lot about
corporate america when
black people ask for equality for
hundreds of years and then they're heard
in a span of three months last year and
the solution was
changing lots of pancakes
you